[Musique]
pour tout d'abord merci à toutes et tous
certains noms vont encore nous nous nous
rejoindre mais merci à ceux qui qui
était qui était à l'heure ce
rassemblement je l'avais souhaité il ya
un an lorsque nous avons eu nos
élections à nos élections internes
je souhaitais qu'on renoue avec ces
rassemblements de jeunes il ya dix ans
que nous ne l'avons pas fait c'était
important de le de leur faire de leur
faire aujourd'hui
et puis
et puis vraiment un gros merci un grand
merci parce que c'était compliqué le coc
vide le confinement changement de date
changement de lieu on a eu à peu près
tout
on a eu aussi quelques grincheux
quelqu'un ronchon il a fallu gérer un
peu tout le monde
tout ça fait que vous êtes là vous avez
relevé ce défi et c'est formidable
merci vraiment d'être là alors un mot
sur l'organisation pour ces deux jours
une chose les gestes barrière savez le
masque et les gestes barrière s'est pas
toujours agréables ceci étant et vaut
mieux ça que le confinement
donc je vous demande vraiment d'y être
très attentif on a pris toutes les
précautions qui convenait mais il faut
aussi que chacun fasse preuve de
responsabilité donc soyez vraiment
attentif à respecter tous les gestes
barrière pendant ces pendant ces deux
jours nous allons avoir des ateliers qui
vont ils vont démarrer très rapidement
quatre ateliers jeux lerhe site
rapidement écologie et croissance c'est
un sujet qui est important c'est ce que
vous nous avez fait remonter des
fédérations c'est à dire que il faut
associer l'écologie à la croissance la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
à la croissance s'est au contraire c'est
une source de dynamisme
ça n'est pas de la décroissance est
exactement le contraire et c'est un des
points que nous allons évoquer après
midi mais on y reviendra aussi demain
démocratie et autorités
la démocratie ça n'est pas l'anarchie
c'est le respect des règles ça veut dire
aussi qu'il faut une autorité qu'ils
soient incarnés ça va faire partie
là aussi des tables rondes que nous
allons avoir république la république
d'aider réussite est bien la république
c'est la capacité à donner à tous et à
toutes les mêmes les mêmes chances
s'impliquent
ça donne des droits mais ça applique
aussi des règles et enfin l'europe et
les souverainetés nationales
l'europe et les souverainetés nationales
beaucoup de sujets sont liées à l'europe
la politique commerciale l'union
européenne peut pas être le le déversoir
de produits qui sont élaborés sans
respecter les normes et les contraintes
que l'on impose à nos à nos paysans ou à
no one on one aux industriels
l'europe c'est aussi l'immigration c'est
aussi la politique de la défense c'est
aussi la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
donc nous allons
et battre dans les ateliers tout
l'après-midi sur ces sujets et puis vers
je regarde bien mes fiches vers 17
heures oui c'est vers 17 heures nous
allons nous retrouver à nouveau dans
cette salle 17h 17h30 comme on a pris un
peu de haut un peu de retard au tour de
de guillaume pelletier et dany genevard
avec les rapporteurs dans l'es4 des
quatre tables rondes pour faire un rendu
en salle plénière à 18 heures un petit
break avec la possibilité de faire de
sport
un certain nombre d'activités 19h01
petit souper au lit de parfum en fait on
a prévu un peu autre chose quand même
alors maintenant je voudrais avant que
nous allions dans les ateliers donnés la
personne à 2 de locaux
l'étape tout d'abord à pierre bédier
mais je dire un mot avant pour que
pierre nous a que nous adressent un mot
d'accueil d'abord pierre c'est un ami
c'est un vieux compagnon
on a avec un certain nombre qui sont en
question ici j'ai pu regarder la
première rangée pas tous parce qu'un
certain nombre était pas né quand on
représentait la jeune garde du rpr et
voilà pierre c'est un compagnon de route
c'est
c'est aussi sans faire offense à ses
successeurs le maire historique de
mantes la jolie
celui qui en 95 a fait tomber un bastion
il y en a un autre à meaux qui est tombé
y en a d'autres aussi à cette époque des
bastions qui semblait imprenable
et si vous voulez savoir comment on fait
campagne dans une terre hostile et
comment on gagne vous avez avec pierre
un vrai expert et puis au delà de ça
pierse et c'est un militant c'est un
militant dans l'âme c'est aujourd'hui le
président du comité de à la fois de la
fédération départementale des yvelines
et du conseil départemental des yvelines
c'est tel esprit de compagnonnage c'est
l'amitié c'est la convivialité avec avec
la pointe d'accent qui la gardait des
terres d'ovalie
c'est tout cela donc je suis vraiment
ravi et fier d'être ici dans ton
département et puis que tu puisses vous
adresser quelques mots pour pour
démarrer cette séance
[Musique]
merci merci christian alors quelques
mots pour vous accueillir dans les
yvelines puisque christian jacob
rappeler que je préside le conseil
départemental des yvelines ce
département je ne peux pas vous dire le
contraire vous l'imaginez bien c'est le
département le plus extraordinaire mais
je trouve que c'est un département
d'actualité pour nous ici les yvelines
c'est d'abord ça n'était bien entendu
pas un département à l'époque mais une
terre qui a été la terre dans laquelle
les premiers capétiens au labour et
cette terre pour créer ce qui devait
devenir la france et nous avons la
caractéristique ce département d'être le
berceau de cet état nation qu'est la
france nous avons quatre villes quatre
villes voici avec saint-louis
mantes-la-jolie avec henri iv saint
germain en laye avec louis xiv puis
naturellement versailles encore avec
louis xiv et d'autres avoir été
plusieurs fois capitale de la france et
ça n'est pas anodin un moment où on voit
bien que les questions qui tournent
autour de l'organisation du monde et en
particulier de la place de l'état nation
sont centrale et dans la crise que nous
avons vécue qui fait que l'on respire
tousse mal et bien cette réflexion sur
l'état nation n'oublions jamais que pour
cette vieille nation qu'est la france
elle est née puis les yvelines c'est un
département récente d'un département
jeunes dans une manifestation jeunes
c'est pas mal mais c'est surtout un
département qui a été créé par le
général de gaulle c'était quand même une
époque où on savait prendre des
décisions et quand il s'agissait
d'organiser la france on savait s'y
prendre voilà pourquoi mon cher
christian le choix de ce département des
yvelines me paraît être un bon choix et
c'est aussi un bon choix parce que c'est
toi qui l'a fait alors tu m'as dit que
tu étais mon ami oui c'est vrai au nez
des habits mettait d'abord mon chef
parce que je suis tu parlais du rpr de
cette culture où je crois à la culture
du chef pas trop de verticalité
mais il en faut quand même parce
qu'autrement c'est le bordel et je veux
te dire christian qu'avait
rondeurs mais fermeté avec réactivité
souvent parce que dieu sait que
l'actualité ne manquent pas tu as donné
un autre mouvement politique un nouvel
élan j'en doutais pas parce que je te
connais depuis suffisamment longtemps
mais je voulais tant remercier et plutôt
que de m'applaudir tout à l'heure
applaudi si christian maintenant s'il
vous plaît 3e 3e bonnes raisons d'être
là c'est naturellement d'accueillir
valérie pécresse jeu presque envie de
dire pour la seconde fois
la première fois c'était après longtemps
c'était quand jacques chirac m'avait dit
il faut y les premiers à valérie d'être
député dans des mers de toi bon on sait
démerdé cher valérie ce fut un plaisir
que de takrit ya dans les yvelines c'est
à nouveau un plaisir de te retrouver
parmi nous car nous les vieux chiraquien
nous savions bien qu'il n'y a pas de
victoire sans rassemblement et le
rassemblement ne peut se faire et c'est
ce que christian pratique
quotidiennement et je l'en remercie
encore que dans une démarche de
collectifs penser que la vie politique
que la vie politique ne peut reposer que
sur de l'individualisme et l'erreur
mortel que bien d'entre nous ont souvent
commises
voilà pourquoi je suis heureux de te
voir là valérie et avant ces échéances
qui nous attendent
ne nous trompons pas d'échéance ce sont
des échances d'abord locale les
cantonales semi local semi national et
régional les autres échéances eux
viendront plus tard et alors tu vas pas
m'empêcher dire deux mots là-dessus oui
je sais toi et bien aimé je sois plus
brefs mais j'ai lu cet été une phrase
qui va plaire à jean michel fourgous
jean michel brousse ils adorent ils
adorent auscitaine stein enstein a dit
la folie sert faire toujours la même
chose en espérant un résultat différent
ne voyaient dans cette phrase d'einstein
aucun rapport avec la primaire aucun
mais n'empêche que c'est une doctrine
que je tombe intelligente et qui
pourrait s'appliquer si ça n'a pas
marché une fois c'est pas en
recommençant ça marchera une seconde il
ya une autre chose que j'ai envie de
dire
cette deuxième chose c'est qu'un parti
politique qui n'a pas de candidat à une
élection majeure comme l'élection
présidentielle est un parti politique
qui meurt le premier parti de france en
1958 c'était le parti communiste premier
parti de france
d'accord il est mort très vite parce
qu'il n'avait pas de candidat à
l'élection présidentielle 1965 ils ont
fait l'effort les foreurs pas l'effort
mais l'erreur de choisir monsieur
mitterrand ils ont essayé de corriger le
tir le coup d'après mais en 1974 ils ont
recommencé et après c'était trop tard le
parti communiste est mort donc mes chers
amis la politique pour les vieux comme
nous c'est d'abord un combat collectif
mais c'est aussi une espérance et nous
rentrons dans une campagne électorale
pour la gagner s'il ya un secret c'est
d'abord celui là est donc même si on
n'est pas sûr de gagner on y va peu
importe
parce que autrement eh bien on n'est pas
digne de vouloir construire une
espérance avec ses concitoyens
on ne peut pas être dans la combine
acciones on ne peut pas être dans
l'intérêt personnel
on doit être dans la générosité car
c'est elle qui peut permettre d'ouvrir
les voies de l'avenir bienvenue en
yvelines touche bien merci merci pierre
valéry je t'ai appelé ya quelques jours
c'est téléphoné et j'étais proposé de
venir de venir nous adresser un mot
d'accueil on est ici dans ta région dans
notre région dans ton dans ton
département
et puis tu m'a spontanément je veux dire
ça a duré dix secondes tu m'as dit oui
tout de suite
et j'y suis très sensible c'est c'est
pour moi un geste important nous avons
gagné cette région c'est moi je suis élu
comme un certain nombre ici au premier
ou au deuxième rang depuis 20 ans 25 ans
dans la région ile de france la région
on l'a connue avec toutes les majorités
de gauche plus souvent que de droite
parce que c'était encore c'était encore
avant et on a vu ce que tu as porté avec
ta majorité avec notre majorité
la manière dont tu as fait bouger cette
région que ce choix j'irai sur le
d'abord me permettrai de le dire ne
soutient la ruralité
nous les franges est de l'île de france
on avait vraiment le sentiment d'être
oubliés détenir au pain sec et à l'eau à
changer les choses
la politique des transports là aussi je
suis bien placé jean-françois aussi fait
beaucoup de franciliens
on sait aussi combien la région c'est
s'est engagée c'est très important pour
nous la politique touristique
on a aussi un peu de chance des
potentialités importantes au delà de au
delà de paris sur bien sûr les lycées
sur les pôles de recherche sur la
sécurité on l'évoquait on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure sur tous ces sujets les
choses ont bougé
nous avons à l'occasion de ces élections
municipales montrer et notamment en
ile-de-france mayer aussi que quand la
droite est unie
on gagne on a gagné des villes en ile de
france je pense à nos amis du val de
marne qui ont remporté de formidable
victoire y en a eu dans les autres
départements aussi mais le val de marne
a quand même beaucoup marqué par les
villes qu'ils ont pu gagner et moi je ne
doute pas que nous allons gagner à
nouveau la région en étant rassemblées
en étant unis et puis je parlais tout à
l'heure parfois des grincheux ou des
ronchons eh bien on va leur montrer que
la droite elle sait se rassembler et
elle sait gagner ce que nous avons su
faire aux municipales nous devons le
faire au départemental et je ne doute
pas qu ensemble nous le ferons
régionales merci d'être là valérie